[Applaudissements]
vous souvenez-vous ce que vous faisiez
vendredi 13 mars 2020 lorsque le Conseil
fédéral a décrété la fermeture des
écoles pour cause de covid
et bien moi je m'en souviens très bien
parce que ça a été le premier jour d'une
période assez mouvementée à la RTS la
radio de télévision suisse dont j'ai
beaucoup appris et une expérience que
j'aimerais vous partager ce soir donc
vendredi 13 mars 2020 le matin j'avais
rendez-vous avec les responsables des
gouvernements cantonaux de Suisse
romande et avec mes collègues je pense
qu'on a à peu près attendu une heure
avant qu'on vue bien nous ouvrir la
porte
et quand on est entré dans cette salle
surchauffée je crois que le président de
la salle le président de la séance
pardon nous a accueilli avec des mots du
genre c'est la guerre on va tout fermer
séance un peu surréaliste et évidemment
raccourci
à l'issue de laquelle la première chose
que j'ai faite c'est d'appeler ma femme
pour lui dire parce qu'elle est
enseignante délit d'initié tu n'as plus
école à partir de lundi
j'ai appelé un de nos fils en lui disant
tu te dépêches d'aller au magasin de
bricolage pour acheter de quoi tenir le
siège pour la rénovation de notre maison
dans le fond dans la famille critin les
réserves de guerre c'est plutôt peau de
peinture et pot de colle que papier
hygiénique
et ensuite je suis rentré à la maison
pour organiser le grand basculement de
la RTS dans le monde covid et là alors
là ce fut le grand saut dans l'inconnu
comment allez en nous produire nos
émissions en restant à la maison
alors ok on télétravailler déjà mais à
ce point vraiment pas
alors on a inventé des dizaines et des
dizaines nouvelles procédures et comme
vous le voyez sur l'image par exemple
nous présentatrices et présentateurs du
Téléjournal ont dû apprendre à se
coiffer se maquiller toute seule y
compris les hommes les réalisateurs ont
dû mettre des gants chirurgicaux pour
travailler sur les régimes les
journalistes radio des masques pour
parler devant le micro et nous avons
même organisé toute la logistique pour
enfermer dans un bunker les rédactions
de l'actualité au cas où la pandémie
pandémie prendrait des ports processions
disproportionnées ce que nous n'avons
finalement pas fait
pendant cette période nous avons donc
produit à la maison la totalité de notre
offre digitale les deux tiers de la
télévision et à peu près 85% de la radio
et là je vous donne un truc si vous
voulez faire de la radio à la maison le
meilleur endroit du point de vue
acoustique c'est le placard à balais
et voilà que trois jours plus tard le
gouvernement suisse décrète l'état de
situation exceptionnelle et pour la
première fois depuis la guerre
probablement nous avons diffusé ce
message sur nos antennes recommandations
du Conseil fédéral rester à la maison en
particulier si vous êtes malade ou si
vous avez 65 ans ou plus sortez
uniquement si vous devez aller
travailler et ne pouvez pas travailler à
domicile ou si vous devez aller chez le
médecin ou à la pharmacie ou si vous
devez acheter de la nourriture ou aider
quelqu'un le Conseil fédéral et la
Suisse compte sur vous
ce jour là la Suisse s'est arrêtée
et quand il se passe plus rien
plus de vie politique plus de vie
sociale plus de sport plus de concerts
plus de festivals chez nous c'est
silence radio écran noir
alors nos équipes ont fait preuve d'une
réactivité et d'une créativité admirable
en quelques jours il a fallu réinventer
les émissions et toutes les semaines
redessiner les grilles de programme
pendant cette période notre mission de
service public a été appris un sens
encore plus fort que d'habitude comme le
disait le slogan que nous diffusions à
l'époque nous étions là avec vous plus
que jamais pour vous informer vous
accompagner et vous divertir
je me suis demandé comment je pourrais
représenter ce que nous avons vécu
pendant cette période et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et voilà ce que ça donne
c'est joli
alors ça n'est pas un ver de terre mais
c'est exactement la courbe du changement
d'Elizabeth Kubler Ross cette courbe qui
décide les étapes émotionnelles par
lesquelles nous passons lorsque nous
vivons par exemple un deuil ou une
transformation dans la première période
nous avons vécu une phase fulgurante
d'euphorie de créativité immense comme
je disais nous avons quelques jours et
adapté toutes nos grilles de programmes
façon de travailler nos modes de
production
puis à partir de l'été la deuxième
période était plutôt un plateau une
période pas facile à vivre pas facile à
manager notamment avec des équipes
divisées entre celles et ceux qui
avaient peur et celles et ceux qui
relativiser la situation une période
d'incertitude rappelez-vous une sorte de
tunnel dont on ne sait pas trop comment
on va sortir avec cette fatigue
psychologique qui commençait à peser sur
le moral cette fatigue covid comme on a
appelé
puis la troisième période celle qui
descend c'est après les levées des
restrictions alors là je vous le dis
très simplement mesdames messieurs ça a
été le grand retour en arrière
mais comme nous étions tout feu tout
flamme pendant la première période nous
allions tous et toutes réinventer le
monde et le fameux monde d'après
et bien il ne s'est rien passé en fait
nous sommes nous avons tous retourné
nous sommes tous retournés en arrière en
particulier chinois la RTS on a oublié à
peu près tout ce qu'on avait imaginé
mais c'est tout à fait naturel vous
savez parce que pour survivre nous les
humains on a besoin de retrouver nos
marques d'être rassurés par ce qu'on
connaît
et donc aujourd'hui c'est la dernière
période nous essayons de remonter la
pente en essayant de retrouver les
bonnes pratiques que nous avions pendant
la période covid et en essayant
d'améliorer le système je vous donne
deux exemples le premier c'est le
télétravail ou disons ce qu'on appelle
chez nous le travail hybride qui est un
management hybride
quand nous avons décidé que les gens
retournent notre personnel retourner sur
le site
nous sommes demandés s'il fallait
continuer avec la politique d'avant
puisque nous avions déjà le télétravail
ou s'il ne fallait pas avoir l'audace de
faire un pas de plus
et de décider ce que nous avons décidé
que finalement à la RTS la règle c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de règle c'est que
chaque équipe nous avons 70 métiers
chaque équipe avec son manager convient
de la façon d'équilibrer vie
professionnelle et vie privée
mais en faisant en sorte que les
objectifs soient atteints la qualité
soit atteinte et qu'on ne prétérise pas
le travail des équipes partenaires
deuxième exemple la subsidiarité qui est
un modèle vertueux de délégation de
compétences et de pouvoir c'était
quelque chose qu'on connaît très bien en
Suisse en politique suisse rapport
commune canton état Confédération mais
pas beaucoup dans les entreprises si nos
équipes ont été si performantes ces
créatives pendant la période covid c'est
pas seulement parce que tout le monde
partagait le sentiment d'urgence mais
c'est aussi parce que à ce moment-là
nous leur avons laissé une très grande
autonomie et finalement nous avons fait
descendre le pouvoir de décision le plus
bas possible
quand nous avons créé la cellule
sanitaire ou cellule de crise la seule
instruction que je donnais à la personne
responsable a été la suivante tu décides
tout
mais s'il y a un sujet sur lequel tu
penses ne pas pouvoir décider tu
m'appelles
la subsidiarité c'est une forme de
délégation inversée ça n'est pas
l'échelon supérieur qui délègue une
partie de ses compétences à l'échelon
assez inférieure tout en étant toujours
responsable c'est à l'envers les
échelons inférieurs qui ont a priori
toutes les compétences sauf celles quel
délègue à l'échelon supérieur
en octobre 2020
deuxième vague covid comme si la crise
sanitaire ne suffisait pas voilà qu'une
autre crise s'abat sur nous avec la
révélation publique d'affaires de
harcèlement
qui remontait du passé
nous avons ouvert des enquêtes
indépendantes qui ont avéré certaines
situations et d'autres pas
cette crise a été très violente d'abord
parce qu'elle touchait à l'humain et non
pas au business et avec toute la charge
émotionnelle que vous pouvez imaginer
cette crise a été très violente parce
que nous étions pris sous un faisceau de
pression
interne pression publique pression
médiatique pression politique aussi
puisque la RTS est une entreprise de
service public cette crise a été très
violente également parce que nous avons
dû la gérer à distance avec 60% de notre
personnel à la maison alors je vous
laisse imaginer des réunions du
personnel la direction devant une seule
caméra 1200 personnes connectées
derrière leur écran pour parler de
sujets aussi difficiles sans voir la
réaction des gens sans voir les gens
eux-mêmes
je ne souhaite à personne de vivre une
telle crise d'être à la tête d'une
entreprise aussi ballottée par les flots
mais cette crise que nous avons surmonté
avec succès
et que sur laquelle nous travaillons au
cours aujourd'hui nous a rendu plus fort
et meilleur elle nous a permis de
renforcer notre dispositif de protection
de l'intégrité personnelle et de libérer
la parole elle nous a permis de faire
évoluer la culture d'entreprise avec une
charte engageante de principes
incontournables et de comportement
attendus elle nous a permis de faire
évoluer le management la culture
managériale vers un leadership équitable
et bienveillant
de cette crise j'ai beaucoup appris
beaucoup appris plus que dans la crise
sanitaire encore sur moi-même sur le
rôle de leader et sur les différentes
façons que nous avons toutes et tous de
réagir face à des crises parce que une
crise c'est un puissant révélateur de ce
que nous sommes profondément en tant
qu'individu en tant que collectif en
tant qu'organisation face à une crise on
ne ment pas on ne fait pas semblant
alors j'ai envie ce soir de vous
partager quatre recommandations
qui peuvent se résumer en quatre verbes
oser
oser et encore oser
première recommandation
oser faire face
vous savez l'animal qui est attaqué il a
trois possibilités
soit il fait le mort soyez fui soit il
attaque nous les animaux humains
réagissons exactement de la même manière
face à une crise face à un danger nous
pouvons faire le mort être tétanisé et
attendre que ça passe nous pouvons aussi
fuir nier la réalité se réfugier dans le
passé au risque de commettre les mêmes
erreurs
ces deux premières réactions j'aimerais
ici que nous nous déculpabilisions ces
deux premières réactions sont tout à
fait naturelles parce que pour être en
sécurité pour se protéger il faut se
retirer
mais le repli est une impasse
et si le contexte ne change pas contexte
de crise
comment vais-je pouvoir sortir de cette
impasse si moi je ne change pas
donc la troisième solution attaquer pour
l'animal c'est la meilleure c'est à dire
se dresser face à la crise faire face à
la crise prendre la situation à bras le
corps et comme le judoka épouser les
mouvements de la crise pour en faire un
tremplin
en faisant preuve de créativité et
d'imagination un exemple comment nous
avons fait face
le premier jour de ces révélations
publiques la presse nous a accusés de
cacher ses affaires de harcèlement et
d'organiser la loi du silence
alors pour qu'il y ait aucune ambiguïté
sur ce sujet nous avons le premier jour
décidé courageusement d'ouvrir une ligne
externe pendant trois mois et de
permettre à toute personne ayant
travaillé un jour à la RTS sans limite
de temps dans le passé de témoigner s'il
avait vécu quelque chose de grave je
connais peu d'entreprises et
d'administrations publiques qui ont osé
le faire même après-midi
deuxième recommandation
osez aller au contact il y a rien de
pire que de piloter une crise ou une
transformation en restant dans sa tour
de contrôle il faut descendre sur le
tarmac allez voir les gens discuter avec
les gens les écouter
prendre un peu si vous ne permettez en
pleine figure leur réaction aussi
troisième recommandation
osez être humble
quand il a une crise tout le monde court
vers la direction pour retrouver les
réponses et forcément nous sommes
éduqués avec cette idée que quand on est
chef quand il y a une autorité
supérieure elle c'est évidemment tout
elle peut tout etc mais dans la réalité
je suis désolé c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai c'est peut-être dur à admettre mais
c'est pas vrai moi je crois
qu'une des grandes qualités d'un
dirigeant d'une dirigeante c'est
l'humilité
c'est la capacité de laisser du temps au
doute et aux questionnements avant de
prendre une décision
c'est la conscience qu'une partie de la
réalité nous échappe ce que j'appelle
des angles morts et comme au volant pour
éviter l'accident il faut tourner la
tête de tous les côtés en allant
chercher le maximum d'informations le
plus largement possible et en matière
d'angle mort je suis devenu un
spécialiste
parce que voilà qu'avec cette crise des
affaires de harcèlement du passé nous
avions des situations que nous ne
connaissions pas mais qui était là
devant nous comme des éléphants dans la
pièce
je crois que l'humilité est donc comme
je le disais une valeur cardinale d'un
dirigeant être dirigeant ça n'est pas
tout commandé
mais c'est être capable de rendre les
choses possibles
être dirigeant ça n'est pas tout
contrôler
mais c'est être capable d'activer la
capacité d'action et d'entrepreneuriat
chez notre personnel
être dirigeant ça n'est pas tout savoir
sur tout mais c'est être capable de
promouvoir l'intelligence collective
parce qu'à la fin de la journée c'est
toujours l'équipe qui gagne rarement les
individus et encore moins le chef ou la
chef
quatrième recommandation
osez être positif
le premier jour de la crise également
nous nous sommes dit que si nous
pouvions surmonter cette crise
et bien elle aurait peut-être quelque
chose de bon pour nous qu'elle nous
permettrait d'être meilleur et cette
conviction partagée au sein de la
direction de la RTS a été pendant tous
ces jours et toutes ces semaines et tous
ces mois une boussole pour nous
être positif c'est pas facile tous les
jours surtout en pleine crise croyez-moi
mais ça ne vous donne une force à
soi-même et aux autres très puissantes
et cette force que vous donnez aux
autres et vous la rendront au centuple
être positif c'est pas voir l'avion rose
être naïf c'est voir les choses telles
qu'elles sont avec objectivité
être positif c'est être capable de
repérer les leviers de changement et
notamment toutes les personnes autour de
vous qui ont envie de faire équipe avec
vous pour le changement
être positif c'est au milieu du
brouillard être capable de déceler les
lueurs les petites lueurs et les signes
d'espérance qui seront comme une étoile
polaire pour vous pendant la traversée
être positif c'est avoir la conviction
comme le disait si bien que Paul Claudel
que le pire n'est pas toujours certain
alors
osez être positifs et bonne route
[Applaudissements]